yotsuba les steaks aujourd'hui on va
tester plein de simulateurs plus pourris
les uns que les autres
bienvenue sur goal simulator
nous sommes sur un incroyable monde
ouvert d'environ 6000 hectares et nous
avons juste une main
non elle n'est pas faite pour faire ce
qu'on pensait non je cueillais de
l'herbe pour te la porte et regarde
comme je suis mignon et nous avons juste
le droit de caresser c'est incroyable de
shell le blanc de la route c'est
exactement ça et on a aussi le droit
bien évidemment dû mettre quelques
claques mais c'est très cruel alors on
va se contenter de la caresser comme ça
d'aller aux dates à schumann le jeu fait
150 méga juste parce que le mec amis du
sol partout 150 magasins
ça correspond à 1000 hectares et
attention maintenant on se retrouve
charme et la simulation de tous les
temps où le monde tombe s'il vous plaît
sitting simulator 2 oui ça donne quand
même beaucoup d'adrénaline
bon ça va trouver tout nous sommes juste
assis sur une chaise en bois voilà même
pas se lever causé en eau la lousiane
football à la blonde basket avec lequel
tu meurs dans vite amusé mais tu ne peux
pas atteindre watts
j'ai l'impression d'être surveillés
super étrange comme sensation ah ouais
tu veux faire en date elle de regard
tu étais déjà allé le mec
et voici une simulation de portes
automatiques c'est carrément incroyable
quand cet homme arrivé nous devons nous
ouvrir rue le laisser entrer est-ce que
c'est vega chiant oui je me faire un
café
une simulation d'un ascenseur vous allez
un meeting ne soyez pas en retard
vous avez attendu que la sauce on arrive
au bon étage vous êtes arrivé à temps
pour le meeting et vous avez gagné
oui waiting for the bus simulation la
simulation où tu as toi un bus au milieu
du désert et où tu es juste un banc et
ce mec que ce soit même pas sur le bon
[ __ ] ça je comprendrais jamais assez
la route 63 voilà une route que
j'emprunte jamais mais c'est une voiture
et moi
alors s'il vous plaît je vous demande
pas si vous voulez c'est des pectoraux
mais c'est parce que dès sa mère est
venue me chercher et je me ferais pas de
mal
elle s'est promenée bombail reste plus
qu'une solution le suicide
nous sommes actuellement sur une
simulation de lampadaires qu'est ce
qu'on s'amuse mais attention on peut
quand même choisir de l'allumer ou
l'éteindre c'est le seul poteau
électrique de la forêt aux odeurs villa
garçons jouent bien souvent des bières
génial parce que la caméra tremble comme
pas possible ce qui donne une certaine
gerbe
kalistick somers porte simulator ouais
il amène la flamme olympique
ouais watts oui j'ai pris la france 1
quelle belle cérémonie d'ouverture je
suis tout ému
est ce qu'il est vraiment mort le mec là
il monte les marches j'ai dû prendre
toutes les marches dans la tête en mode
trauma crânien hémorragie interne
dead swimming ok on commence avec donc
la suédine poule
c'est pourquoi déjà quand j'appuie sur
des on passe d'une piscine aux jeux pour
enfants il ya des boules de toutes les
couleurs adacore qu'ils sachent que la
souris c'est pas grave on y va aller on
fait les coop terre et c'est quoi qui
l'a au genou c'est des groupes de
moustiques ou cdd rotule extra large oui
à la manière de se retourner le plus
d'hommes du rock c'est ridicule et tu
sais que ça là j'ai un coach qui est nu
et caraquet de moustache bluff a dansé
un sifflet mais elle est quand même tout
nu et là les enfants
si je fais ça vous criez musculation
watts
le mec de mongolie c'est un cheval et le
mec le mec du canada sasha et moi je
suis à un homme tout
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce jeu au
piège sur la connerie là cet homme
arrive en quoi ah ouais vous n'êtes pas
un peu l'oeil 2 sont roues dans ces
anneaux
975 bas attendait mais fait 10 mètres
non mais on va lui montrer qu'on est
plus fort on va faire 10 m 2 mais
l'armée quai non mais il s'offre à lui
faire un câlin faut passer outre
oui 10 m 2 il a fait combien de mecs du
canada dit m c'est bon où est ce que je
veux c'est faire la callas aube et oui
ça lui comme un ça va
salut il a carrément tiré dessus
non là bas quand ça fait un peu beaucoup
l'homme nu sur le cheval c'est plutôt le
cheval qui me monte
il ne tient en laisse coi le cheval n'a
carrément pris sur chouette pour un
chien alors paul volts taille mais je me
fais un chèque car au bac et je peux pas
faire et regardé home je passe pas je
m'en vais je ne plonge pas je m'en fous
du concours de merde je suis spider man
je m'en vais à une bâche de code
en fait je suis super bad nous sommes
maintenant sur tri simulateur 2013
pourquoi avoir mis deux gros boutons
blancs en faisant semblant que l'un
d'eux est caché derrière les feuilles de
l'arbre
oh merde allez c'est parti playes voilà
je suis un arbre c'est vraiment
passionnant
j'aimerais vraiment être un arbre faire
des choses incroyables comme regarder
d'autres arbres perdre mes feuilles
récupérer mes feuilles voir la nuit
tombée attention ça ça ça se voit qu'une
seule fois dans la vie d'un arbre
c'est une éclipse forestière là par
contre ça commence à devenir carrément
glauque je me suis bien dessus à
l'équité au jeu et c'est sur cette
magnifique petite simulation divers que
nous allons nous quitter
oh il neige c'est si vous à aa
je joue la comédie j'espère que ce petit
best of de simulation le plus pourri que
j'ai pu trouver vous aura plu on se
retrouve dimanche soir dans une nouvelle
vidéo merci avoir regardé celle ci a
bientôt au revoir bah les steaks camp
dément tout le monde pitts 8 h m
costume-cravate sage des pieds comme sa
fiction oh oui je un oui à un peu plus
comme ça je le combats sans se basera
les premiers pas bien pire